and action invaded I said this movie
wisely downtown and Beach kicking ass
[Music]
and thank you
Oh
[Music]
all right that's mostly a little bit
yeah we're like those maybe put your
head on here
[Music]
Oh
oh good morning everybody and welcome to
the channel awesome studio Merry
Christmas Happy Hanukkah happy Kwanzaa
happy holiday it is early
I've got shadow this is really strange
I'm not used to having my facial hair
grow this long I didn't even know with
the girl this long let's go check out
the scent hey there's nothing that Lucas
hey Chris before yeah yeah Oh
introductions yeah reintroduction I say
let me go into focus oh it's one hey
how's it going
hey good good
I'm evil he's very evil people you can
see you can tell by the Cape hmm well
you got to tell about this next messing
lights gonna have here you ready to say
it ready and action
I completely forgot why we came you what
do i do another one like that Bri
oh hey ready and action
I completely forgot why we came here
no wait a second are those Jolly
Ranchers oh so you know is that you just
used tell you're hungry a snack there
you go oh flavor of the dark side are
you dark side sherry
oh oh yeah no you fit that character
really well like either
yeah like a younger version of it looks
so much like an old
man and you act like it wasn't the fight
thing is like you know he so often
you'll see him do is grocery you know
can't calm and cool and stuff like that
be you can do like a lot of funny voices
well your uh what was it like the
unhinged reviews or whatever like what
occultic of the unhinged reviews that
you do don't wear their cousin yeah the
hilarity like there he'll do like all
these impressions and stuff that's all
those things for it's like he's really
good at voice wow thank you
did do a little bit your Wahlberg
Wahlberg um from happening
well guys take an interest in science
your about honeybees hey you guys you're
with honeybees yeah apparently a lot I'm
going missing all over the world
alright let's hear some theories about
why this might be had that's really good
so specific market time I went to the
supermarket and I bought some coughs
here ya know though and this is a really
do that dude use like no it's like you
didn't even have a for have you not
noticed all the posters everywhere I
mean they're just a low voice yes uh
this one go ahead grab the blasts over
there blaster this you're going to bring
this is bird is actually gonna bring
that into frame and you're gonna say I
guess I better go down there and we'll
juices you look like a million Stewart
troopers and say yeah but I can actually
hit anyone still yeah it's just like so
you're banning any right here you praise
a gun light and it just guess I better
go down there you look a million
stormtroopers yeah but I can take it
people have a like route to Mars
justice hand cream
and the chaos everybody with the case
yeah it's a great duck Dodgers uh I
guess I better go down there yeah then
you have like a million stormtroopers
yeah Groucho Marx will set down your
what before was good just okay ready and
action
you have like a million stormtroopers
yeah but I can actually hit something
big prize hey yeah ready and edge I
guess I'll have to go down there but you
have like a million stormtroopers yeah
but I can actually hit something enjoy
one more duel like a minute if I can
actually hit okay yeah yeah I'll try to
do that with that voice yeah ready and
action
guess I'll have to go down there either
kind of Clint
it's all right this is it ready and heck
I guess I'll have to go down there
myself but you have like a more nor
troopers yeah but I can actually it's
very Jack Nicholson knows
it was clicking on the Jolly Ranchers
happen cool
um do me a favor uh Malcolm could you
real fast because I need Walter and
Christmas
can you tell Tamra go ahead tell Tamra
Jim to get in getting her Rea / mother
out fitness oh ok so like have the Ray
outfit under it but she's getting great
for the mother character that makes
sense okay yeah
must be another drill yeah it's true Oh
a bit just a bit man
I remember I'd to wear that thing yeah
yeah you liked it though we didn't it
hurt like Stockholm Syndrome
you grew to like it I grew to like
because otherwise you'd be fired
hmm help me is equivalent the
stormtrooper outfit no Malcolm get in
the suit oh no but he's wearing though
here I'm not certain my order here do we
both get him oh we both try to fit into
amazing that's like some sort of weird
mutant stormtroopers like we were one of
the clone mistakes we came out generally
clothes that sounds like a bread don't
oh yeah Clone Wars is great be you
better believe it right up
oh yeah be confusing few low bow fence
stormtrooper
how would you probably help a trooper
trooper fed trooper fat rip of fat yeah
remember ray having purple hair yeah
what's up with that
okay wait we don't know who her mom is
yet I'm still voting Lou yeah you just
improvising this look all right for the
mum oh yeah maybe a let me see maybe
cover this too with the black the rest
yeah a little bit made just like a black
cloth or something like that just around
that that's like the one thing where
it's like outfit right cuz you're
technically gonna be the same chef but
yeah that's good oh my god
hey Naz white on the set talking you
look different today you're particularly
well animated this morning have you done
something with your face perhaps some
makeup I don't know you just look
different to me that does it all right
and dismissed oh and don't forget that
we're gonna have a meeting like five
more times in the next 24 hours
excellent will you be as well animated
then as you are now do that like to get
me here to fat quite on the set and if
it goes for doing a we're gonna be five
more times the next 24 hours
excellent will you be as well animated
Dan as you are now
probably not well time
oh great
I think it was fairly consistent I just
think we are eyes adjusted to it I just
think it yeah and when he wasn't talking
what he wasn't what he wasn't talking it
was fine the second he moved his lips
I'm like oh so I'm playing Star Wars
Battlefront right leav oh yeah that was
crazy
that was all yeah she she look like that
with a blue horse yellow Oliver I am
really a porcelain doll yeah this one I
don't know loop does does the same
requisite about his movie what the hell
was it cause the great oz agreed yeah
look like that yeah or Dobby the elf
like it's still learning Anna or like an
anime characters yeah
princess Dobby awesome fair release you
are the last of your religion they did
the same thing to Robert Downey jr. in a
civil war let's do one okay this is
gonna be like Leia I don't know because
that was short the key to doing those we
have to keep it short and Tarkin was on
for yes stars yeah he look like a video
games the best an x-wing pilots were
amazing because with space battle to
distract you you can't focus on the face
and there's constant movement I'm the
right that work yeah that really does I
thought that was flesh the original
footage no they just lies a place the
battle today I thought no no I just I
just assume a cgi catch it but oh then
well then no wonder it looks so I
thought it was like original footage
that they didn't use that just replace
oh I'll take your word for it that would
make sure for sure
you're somethin that would explain why
I'm so good because it was it was real I
need some time just like I think he was
in the shadows and if he wasn't he
wasn't talking when he was like yes yeah
the first thing we should have is
distort reflection are there like we got
yeah you're on right there was a weird
scene tumor than the camera like yeah
and he does like this little chicken
wing yeah it's like looking oh yeah
that's weird look you don't do that no
my dad is gonna do it I can just do it
right now yeah let's turn your just a
whip just like a witch with watching all
the way we made you sit regino at some
point
oh no I didn't I thought you didn't like
it or love it or hate it love it
I'm kind of just like it's o9u like oh
you better get this right home alone
yeah jingle all the way
yeah go outside it'll stand in the
snow for 20 minutes and think about what
you just did it was kind of funny
you stand up in the wood with the
beginning you just don't good I hear
myself I like did ironic right yeah we
like to ironically come on yeah put that
cookie down
watch your body right there though okay
cookie down towards indication they're
like yeah what's over here
your Austrian father good hey I mean so
when it is bad store oh I'm sorry I
can't
well we're come on good burger yeah it's
embedded cinnamon is like brick the
black comedy
oh come on go Jesse never comes just
sucked out of the university first kid
hey that matter yes it's great you guys
make first Sinbad oh really
I think it's my first big heavy nesting
good burger
wow that's a good one to do never some
massive le a big go to one oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah guys wait nice guys
you didn't kill the night I saw yeah
yeah this is the world that is we're
awesome
Oh perfect Nickelodeon slime mm-hmm no
niggling slime is awesome but we we had
that we started that with you yeah
what's the American start dominating
student event Oh if you wash everything
right then you are so sorry your liking
Sinbad I didn't like Sinbad
you always awake at like Horace Mann so
I thought he was Sinbad yes thank you
not really laughing oh I will say I'm
just go ahead that just come back
applause that laugh is so legit yeah
it's almost like Hector ha ha ha ha
Randy Walton yeah and egg the mantle
racial name saw wait is he saw trust me
I figured out this once the movie is
over
ah yeah you'll forget obviously all
these names how would you say from his
name is Sir the men Horatio make saw
wait his name is saw is it trust me
you'll forget all these names when the
movies aren't taken yeah just in the
time trust me forget all these names
watch the movie is over and secret plans
and what is their secret plan said we
need you to infiltrate oh I'm gonna put
in a new battery
ok so pretty much like you're going to
be offspring
gun goes boom like that it's going to be
like just a guy behind or even just
something there is it just blows up and
it's like this is in the prison so it's
like you're free to just like ahh and
you're stuck to go this way and Walter
you just go by just or grab my hair like
this and uh yeah Tammy you're just like
oh you don't sound like a big gorging
kid kind of thing you see me grab her
they're like yeah so pretty much like as
soon as I say action
boom it's kind of like boom and then you
just immediately start walking very
slowly good if you want to grab this
okay rip her head off man just rip off
this cap do it it's dual life I'll take
another step back Walter alright ready
to travel and action
it was really good yeah I'm this one
step like you know oh great and I get a
hoop action tell ya
lots of hoo-ha Jenna Bravo uh Tammet a
campus stuff this week good it's nothing
i Walter one more step back there you go
perfect
hey great and actually sis assistant
good
oh one more um on this one too like hey
you can make a neat idea Nami you can
make like fun okay really Walter yeah
retail and very good yeah I think I'm
just gonna do all their scenes before I
do ours then alright I want to really be
like this by this I will probably move
in a little wider just as a nice thing
is it's a very move and if you make it
oh yeah let's go ahead
hello towards you and then we'll be back
[Applause]
[Music]
so did they did Jim built this gym did
you know no we no no I am astounded
actually we plotted it I mean no did you
build this specifically for this review
just to know so he voted for a real
movie oh okay yeah building ships oh
they're magnetic oh that's smart that's
really cool and we can change up to 750
gals gonna say that's true we can just
move the pieces around man when we need
a different say yeah yeah that's a good
idea
we could also change the color of these
things by not gonna show okay well
definitely for the Darth Vader thing how
long because red as possible they'll
probably a lot impose
[Applause]
and we're gonna we're gonna have to
breathe on one side
all right sleeve ever experienced Oh cut
off and uh I do go take it down or
kneeling to see how it looks so okay get
your positions
okay Malcolm a step here and left and
there's not too much room to go okay
hold on a Doug here right just a touch
just a touch okay Jim look at me now
that looks great okay well it's going to
be then we're gonna act like uh you know
you're in that position but at the
beginning you're gonna be up in work I'm
going to say action braga turn look
pretty much at the door I'll say aim we
all aim now we're waiting and then I'll
say fire and we're acting like we're
pirate and stuff like that which is you
know little gauge okay and bar yeah
thanks just yeah yeah but just really
cool um and yeah we kept there we go a
different angle after that am i high
stakes am i beginning standing uh yeah
you're beginning stand okay
recording dad rolling all right guys
ready and action
and fire
yes crisp it's might be a little too
much recoil the gun was like if you're
gonna throw it and post up the gun was
there like don't don't do it like oh
yeah yeah why yeah cuz you're throwing
laser blasts in right and ghosts yeah
yeah yeah I just wouldn't do it
like quite bad yes okay okay cool oh and
still recording
yep ready and action and fire
[Music]
yep there's a good gym that's a great
face I'd love it
let's go ahead oh gosh understand I mean
no am I looking in those lines are past
it uh Bella I get the door
that's the lens to me okay fine I do I'm
just ask no no no but fine yeah you want
me to spot it okay you know what
looking good look at Walter look
for Walter Walter yeah yeah well yeah
perfect Alan yeah okay cool
all right charlie yep Rowan all right
all right so I say action just hold the
visitor in the action
fine go ahead look more worried I don't
know what that was
weed over salad oh uh just more like Oh
cheap this slightly by the way great
inspiration Rob I don't know what that
was not so great look at this blue wire
here try that then it'll make sense your
face no not the all right I see my
glasses off okay right up around here
looking there first
yeah hold like she's looking at and all
that like that's his eyeline right like
that
here hold my face all right okay the
camera is there you go a little to the
right
it's like so close to looking directly
into that am I in the shot all right
that way okay perfect right there do you
see me or not uh do your thing anyway
about them okay sundae's we catch video
shot oh yeah you're you're in the shots
W okay and all right action
action fight good well good
yep go
Malcolm doesn't know about this but
we're all really tired when they're
still filming
[Music]
far2
okay
really the end actor
okay Oh Sister Sister I dunno oh yeah
you're at home of that Bader outfit yeah
you I was explaining the dog like it's
easier breathing out of my Tiger head
and then this well then have like that
your mouth but yeah open up yeah it's a
mouthful Vincent got a fan built into a
two dozen yeah yeah it also has a fan I
just like to say I love the way oh no I
love though you were right there because
like it looked like badir' with your
crotch oh yeah Oh your house is so big
[Music]
cool yeah the rest is just you do in the
police
[Music]
you